mais d'abord le président de la
république devant le congrès des maires
de france pour la dernière fois de son
quinquennat à la fin de son discours
allez en entendre un extrait il a il a
choisi quand même un peu de
calinothérapie de leur a rendu hommage
regarder que c'est ce qui vous tient au
quotidien et c'est ce que nous allons
continuer de faire quelles que soient
les vents mauvais quelles que soient les
esprits de division de discorde qui
parfois règne parce que ce que nous
avons collectivement accompli avec
toutes celles et ceux qui oeuvrent à nos
côtés
c'est un travail de résistance inédit à
une crise séculaire mais c'est aussi la
capacité à bâtir notre avenir
est à construire l'espérance qui va nous
permettre de regarder devant
et avec cela
acer nation véritablement
il ya dans le beau mot de mer
l'anagramme du verbe aimer
parce qu'au delà de tout ce que vous
faites il ya un engagement qui est de
coeur et d'âme et quelque chose qui ne
se réduit pas aux politiques publiques
parfois au sujet
un peu difficile ou techniques que nous
avons pu aborder aujourd'hui mais
c'était bien normal et légitime
oui toujours cette part de sens
d'affection
d'accouchement
voilà pour ce premier extrait du
discours présidentiel public sénat vous
le savez est partenaire de ce congrès
des maires de france d'ailleurs en
profiter pour féliciter toutes les
équipes de la chaîne pour le dispositif
qui a été mis en place on n'a rien rater
de cet événement qui était attendu et
qui a donc placé david lisnard à la
présidence de l'association des maires
de france on boucle ce soir dans ce sens
public cette séquence après le discours
du président et je vous présente mes
invités laurence lemouzy bonsoir
vous êtes docteur en sciences politiques
directrice de la revue pouvoirs locaux
et directrice de l'institut de la
gouvernance territoriale on soir
catherine tricot bienvenue à vous aussi
vous êtes directrice de la revue regards
à vos côtés stewart show bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes consultant en
stratégies d'opinion chez viavoice avec
nous également en visioconférence julien
mouzon qui est la fondatrice d'élu local
bonsoir julia mouzon c'est un réseau
national de femmes élues et puis à mes
côtés laetitia cru païni torriani cette
position soit laetitia on va faire un
premier tour de table j j intègre
évidemment julia mouzon même serré pas
autour de cette table avec nous une
réaction au discours présidentiel on a
choisi un extrait qui est à la fin du
discours mais finalement moi j'ai le
sentiment qu'il a plutôt défendu son
bilan face au faso mer et pas forcément
beaucoup lâché de lest on reviendra en
détail sur sur les différentes
thématiques qu'est ce que vous retenez
de ce discours laurence lemouzy pour
commencer alors si je voulais reprendre
la chute qui a été la sienne sur la
nagra mais je dirais qu'il m'a fait
penser un peu un roman de même deux
romans de jane austin c'est orgueil et
préjugés raison et sentiments d'ailleurs
orgueil et préjugés il a parlé de
préjugés de malentendus au début du
quinquennat un récit de la discorde
qu'il a eu du mal à maîtriser qui malgré
je pense des intentions à ses lacets
authentique au début on installe énième
récit entre l'état et les collectivités
je t'aime moi non plus la raison c'est
un peu la partie centrale il y a des
chiffres qui prouvent que j'ai dit ce
que j'ai fait j'ai fait ce que j'ai dit
et puis il ya les sentiments parce qu'il
a appris aussi probablement à mieux
connaître les maires il a rappelé que
lui-même n'était pas n'avait jamais eu
un mandat local en particulier n'avait
été maire d'ailleurs comment précédent
président de la république et pas
n'importe lequel puisqu'il s'agit du
général de gaulle et puis parce qu'il
sait que le maire est un élément
essentiel du lien social comme le sont
les élus locaux et que peut-être il a il
les a trop pris pour des prestataires de
service il n'a pas été le seul mais une
compétence compétences déléguées légal
prestataires de services on oublie quand
il gère certes des lieux mais ils gèrent
et hilda ministre beaucoup de liant on
va reprendre évidemment en détail
certaines des des informations vous avez
dit vrai notamment écoutera cet extrait
ou où il ya une comparaison assez habile
avec le général de gaulle finalement
catherine tricot qu'est ce que vous
retenez de ce discours moi je pense que
c'est un discours qui était un peu sur
la défensive parce que finalement le
compte n'est pas rennes n'est pas soldé
et il n'est pas soldé sur le fond c'est
après simplement par des maladresses et
au fond dans le logiciel d'emmanuel
macro n'y a pas beaucoup de place pour
la dynamique de la société en effet les
maires ils les voient comme des gens qui
gèrent le lien social ce qui l'a dit
d'ailleurs alors que les maires ils sont
pas simplement des gestionnaires du bout
du lien du fonctionnement mais aussi ils
sont en contact avec les énergies dans
les territoires ce qu emmanuel macron
intègre pas du tout dans son discours
quand dans sa perspective quand il sent
pas les territoires sahraouis moi je
pense que j'ai nommé ce que je pensais
quand il parle par exemple de construire
le futur il était assis il a beaucoup
parlé il n'a pas beaucoup écouté quand
même quand si on se souvient bien du
grand débat april et gilet jaune c'était
quand même pas tout à fait un grand
débat c'est un grand saut lille hoc dans
lequel on lui posait des questions mais
quand emmanuel macron et non sa vision
c'est quand même une vision dans lequel
la mobilisation il ya la mobilisation
des start-up heures certes mais la
mobilisation de la société n'est pas
vraiment présent et moi j'ai noté le
surcroît de mobilisation des élus des
maires qui ont participé à ces fortement
un tiers d'entre eux à l'élection du
nouveau président et je crois que ça
signifiait un nouvel engagement et une
certaine défiance des élus à l'égard de
ce pouvoir qui a été très verticale est
très peu sensible au territoire et à la
décentralisation vous nous faites un
bilan du
seulement du divin
j'ai trouvé que c'était un un président
un peu candide a aussi qui s'apprêtait à
affronter un rapport de force politique
et qui se posait la question est ce que
en 2022 il pourra faire sans les
territoires
l'épreuve du pouvoir ces cinq années ont
montré que non elle n'a pas la faveur
des deux crises que l'on a connues gilet
jaune écrit sanitaires il s'est rendu
compte qu'effectivement les territoires
est un rouage essentiel finalement de du
pouvoir et puis il faut se rappeler
aussi que c'est un emmanuel macron ou le
disait très justement qui a été en
difficulté surtout des échéances
démocratique intermédiaires sous son
quinquennat municipales régionales a été
en difficulté d'imprégner le maquereau
nisme dans les territoires donc
effectivement je trouve c'est un
discours du en même temps assez habile
entre effectivement le bilan qu'il
défend le l'acte qui prend aussi de de
cette opinion publique qui veut plus de
régions plus de territorialisation dans
l'est dans les prises de décisions et en
même temps il dit qu'on le fera à sa
manière donc je pense qu'il ya un habile
habillage je dirais politique derrière
derrière tout cela jules à mouzon est ce
qui vous a convaincu
alors
pas complètement david lisnard a parlé
du constat de recentralisation et c'est
effectivement ce soulignent mes
collègues sur ce plateau c'est le
constat est le sentiment d'une
dissociation entre une volonté que je
pense ce sincère et réel une volonté de
renouer ce lien une volonté de recréer
ce lien avec les territoires que le
président de la république a aussi
manifesté lors de ces grands entretiens
lors du mouvement des gilet jaune donc
une volonté très forte mais en même
temps une difficulté voire une
incapacité à faire donc là le terme de
constat de recentralisation est assez
juste et effectivement emmanuel macron
s'est opposé quelque part aux élus
locaux et aux territoires sur une
nombreuse sur de nombreux sujets de son
quinquennat que ce soit le sujet est
évidemment de la taxe d'habitation le
temps des gilet jaune pour la santé
profondément clivé entre entre les
territoires et entre la présidence de la
république le temps du coureur un virus
aussi où les élus appelée de leurs voeux
une confiance une décentralisation une
délégation des responsabilités et des
compétences qu'ils n'ont pas vu venir et
je rejoins le terme de prestation de
services qui a été évoquée effectivement
ce qu'on entend dans ce discours c'est
un président de la république qui
s'opposent toujours dans une position
hiérarchique vis-à-vis des élus locaux
une position hiérarchique avec des élus
qui rendent service qui qui
qui accomplissent des missions au
service de l'état le président la
république a cité le fait que les élus
étaient aux côtés de l'état il se pose
aussi dans une posture de protection et
là il a mentionné les réformes du
quinquennat que ce soit sur les frais de
garde d'enfant il a mentionné la réforme
de la formation des élus mais dans les
faits ces réformes et la formation des
élus en est un très bon exemple sont
très très limité pour les pour les élus
locaux et on l'a aussi vu d'ailleurs
avec la dernière intervention m'a
totalement absurde le chef de l'état se
place un peu au dessus des mers
hiérarchiquement pardon de réagir à ça
les dix siècles pas un mot alors comment
j'ai trouvé sur les secours la de ce que
je viens d'entendre le discours s'est
alors moi je sais qu elle m'en imprégner
par le livre que je suis en train de
vivre qui a vraiment remarquable la
marque macron me raphaël lorca est
effectivement en fait quand j'entends
emmanuel macron dans ce discours il est
vraiment l'incarnation d'une neutre
neutre ne veut pas dire mot vide creux
mais neutre c'est le à la fois caressant
vous l'avez dit est à la fois offensif
et c'est ce qui caractérise vraiment
toujours emmanuel macron c'est à dire
que c'est pas une synthèse du plus c'est
du moins c'est juste l'incarnation du
plus et du moins bon je vous je vous
allez vous les avez retrouvé ça dans le
discours complètement voilà c'est quand
même moi l'incarnation et sauf ce que je
viens d'entendre en fait j'ai échappe
sans qu'il n'ait que même un peu
uniformiser de l'interaction entre les
maires et emmanuel macron c'est à dire
que tous les observateurs s'entendent
sur le fait que emmanuel macron a
finalement confisqué tous les pouvoirs
des maires et les maires ont appelé à
plus de liberté d'autonomie dans leur
action et c'est bon ben moi je demande
quand même à vérifier c'est à dire que
il me semble quand même que pendant la
crise sanitaire on entendait davantage
d'appels au secours à l'état qui devait
tout faire qui devait protéger tout le
monde qui devait arroser tout le monde
de ses finances publiques pour sauver le
pays plutôt que des initiatives il y en
a eu 1 je ne dis pas bien sûr qu'il y en
a eu de façon ponctuelle des initiatives
qui partait d'en bas c'est à dire de la
mairie pour apporter sur la table des
solutions pour le pays et méthodes pour
son exemple aussi il me semble que
vraiment je file il savait les traits
d'une enquête concrète avec ce qui a été
fait ville ville par ville vous vous
dites c'est un comportement qui est
parfois un peu adolescents des
territoires vis-à-vis de l'état ça
rejoint ce lien de ce que vient de dire
avec tessa cru pas oui il ya une façon
il ya un je t'aime moi non plus c'est à
dire protège moi quand j'en ai besoin
mais laisse moi libre de faire quand
même ce que je veux donc si ce rapport
adolescents mais
les maires n'ont plus vraiment de
pouvoir entre nous il ya quand même une
absence dans le débat c'est
l'intercommunalité en l'intercommunalité
ce n'est pas vraiment de la
décentralisation
d'ailleurs je pense qu on est à la fin
de la saison une de la décentralisation
l'intercommunale pouvoir qui a le
pouvoir des élus désignés par des
contres pour lequel on vote pendant les
municipales et qui des conseillers
municipaux qui vont représenter les
dites ville au conseil communautaire
mais les intercommunalités répondent
quand même à des contractualisations de
politiques publiques impulsé mais ils
vont ils vont prendre les marchés
publics plus important et donc ils vont
avoir
ministration et demi sera soumise à une
illustration t structuré que dans l'est
que dans les villes c'est certain lui
est parfois critiqué pour être un peu
trop techno les
ils se sentent à juste titre par moment
les maires des possédés par ce que n'ont
pas non plus une technicité on les
renvoie à gérer leurs communes comment
gérer un syndic de copropriété alors que
la vraie arène politique là où il se
débat des projets soit sur ans et c'est
au sein des intercommunales or on va
revenir quand même au au contenu du
débat de du président a vu du discoure
pardon du du président de la république
il a voulu solder en quelque sorte les
dossiers tendu flora sauvage
dialogue et confiance de notions qui ont
cruellement manqué dans les relations
entre les maires et l'état au cours du
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron à quelques
mois de la présidentielle il a néanmoins
tenté de renouer avec les élus locaux
malgré des relations tendues j'ai
beaucoup entendu monter ces dernières
années un discours ambiant qui était
trop souvent les élus contre l'état
je pense que ce débat je vous le dis en
toute sincérité est un débat mortifère
le président nouvellement élu de
l'association des maires de france david
lisnard a déploré la centralisation des
décisions le premier constan que nous
faisons est celui de l'extrême
centralisation des décisions
y compris parfois au détriment de l'état
déconcentré lui même
combien de préfet
je me suis laissé dire parfois même deux
ministres ont découvert les décisions en
même temps que nous même reproche venant
de la mer de paris est candidate à la
présidentielle presse sur la gestion de
la crise sanitaire
face aux crises l'état monsieur le
président a fait son possible mais les
collectivités ont fait tout le reste
l'unité elle se construit par la
confiance une confiance qu'il va falloir
renouer à l'aune de la présidentielle
alors on essaie de savoir ce que ce
qu'attendaient les les élus les maires
étaient présents au congrès du discours
du printemps république pur style
jourdain nous rejoindre soir
un venu hier pas mal de revendications
mine de rien oui j'y étais j'ai dit on
s'est croisé berger pas le tee shirt et
on s'est croisé effectivement alors j
étais hier ce congrès de la mecque j'ai
pu prendre en quelque sorte un le pouls
des élus alors il ya trois grands sujets
de frustration thomas le premier est
bien gros seins de la réforme de la taxe
d'habitation qui a été engagé par
emmanuel macron taxe d'habitation qui a
été supprimé sur les résidences
principales et ça ça ne passe pas du
tout chez les mères des taxes
d'habitation a pendant longtemps et est
un des leviers en des finances locales
elles participent et un certain
équilibre financier pour les communes la
fin de la taxe d'habitation c'est moins
de ressources pour les collectivités
donc les maires ne sont pas contents ils
contestent cette suppression mais
difficile de demander une nouvelle
réforme un retour d'une nouvelle taxe à
quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle et ça emmanuel macron l'a
très bien compris écoutez c'était il ya
quelques minutes au congrès des maires
de france la taxe d'habitation était un
impôt formidable c'était un impôt dont
le premier contribuable était l'état
c'est l'état qu'il payait alors pouvait
monter et on s'était pas douloureux pour
les gens en général
c'était un impôt sur les classes
moyennes c'était un impôt mauvais pour
les petites villes de venir juste et
c'était un impôt à travers notre
histoire que progressivement
les contribuables en vrai payer de moins
en moins parce que l'état le compenser
si c'est ça l'autonomie fiscale ça
s'appelle pas liberté responsabilité
président autres sujets de frustration
thomas pour les mères la dette qu'ovide
pour pallier les défaillances de l'état
au plus fort de la crise les mairies ont
dû mettre la main à la poche achats de
masques achats de gel dépensons
personnels municipaux achats de services
la facture s'élèverait à 6 milliards
d'euros sur l'association des maires de
france david lisnard le nouveau patron
de l'aef demande à l'état de régler la
note mais pour l'instant c'est niet
c'est le gouvernement refuse de mettre
la main à la poche et puis derniers
sujets de frustration thomas
l'impression de perdre chaque jour un
peu plus de compétences de perdre des
marges de manoeuvre pour gérer les
communes il considère qu'on peut que
souhaiter annuel macro et bien l'état
sans quelques centres e centralisée
alors un texte sera étudiée sera examiné
par l'assemblée nationale au mois de
décembre un texte qui est présenté par
le gouvernement comme un nouveau l'acte
de la décentralisation mais pour les
élus locaux vient ça suffit pas il
faudra dans les mois à venir remettre
sur la table ce dossier les libertés
locales tu m'as merci beaucoup au stif
pour ses explications donc ça c'était
juste avant le discours du présent
république mais on vient de recevoir à
l'instant des réactions c'est vraiment à
chaud des maires de france depuis le le
congrès dans les minutes qui ont suivi
le discours des macros la question de la
réforme de la taxe d'habitation me
laisse encore un petit peu perplexe et
je pense qu'un certain nombre de nos
collègues sont dans la tente d'une
véritable autonomie fiscale et
financière pour les collectivités demain
on verra bien ce qu'il en sera dans les
mois et les années à venir mais dans
l'ensemble s'il fallait remettre les
choses en perspective d'un lien avec les
différents gouvernements de ces
dernières années les territoires ont su
trouver leur place et ont été à mon sens
davantage écouter ça a plutôt commencé
de manière cordiale le ton je les
trouvais assez rude vis-à-vis des mères
que nous sommes
le donneur de leçons voire même un peu
beaucoup voilà on a un petit peu
l'habitude dans tous les cas de vue de
mon prise pas moi j'ai malheureusement
l'habitude d'écouter le président la
république
avoir un ton un peu
professoral
chacun reste sur ses positions nous on
pense que
on était
des poussées un peu de nos prérogatives
le président pense qu'il nous en lui
on se plaint tous les miens se plaignent
et sur le terrain tous les jours quand
on me l a jeune a compté nous prend à
l'envers et on se rend compte que
finalement
il a le dernier mot et que qu'est-ce qui
fait c'est parce que
si votre chose c'est intéressant parce
que on ya beaucoup de réactions quand
même on dire négative ou ou à s'est
distanciée mais ça ça rejoint aussi le
manque d'implantation locale du parti à
l'om c'est une faiblesse du du président
et c'est une faiblesse dans le bilan de
son quinquennat oui c'est une faiblesse
je dirais même dans la philosophie
politique du maquereau nisme parce que
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire que le
mécanisme à l'épreuve des territoires ça
c'est une question qui nous avait
mobilisé longuement dans les murailles
municipal durant les régionales et je
pense que c'en est aussi l'une des
expressions les plus les plus claires
alors moi je ne vais pas une expertise
des politiques territoriales ni de ce
que peuvent penser aujourd'hui les élus
locaux mais enfin quand on regarde d'un
point de vue de l'opinion finalement ce
qu'on se danse on rencontre c'est qu'il
ya une aspiration très très forte a
effectivement des cendres de plus en
plus les décisions pour autant et c'est
ça qui est intéressant c'est que les
français n'y voit pas très clair non
plus à l'échelle des territoires lors le
maire est tracé bien identifié c'est
vrai ya une forme de confiance absolue
que l'on a à cet élu de proxinvest l'élu
préféré des français absolument la
région juste après mais je pense qu'il
ya aussi d'un point de vue la plus
politique discovery tic finalement
emmanuel macron qui qui s'adresse aussi
à une france qui n'a pas forcément non
plus l'information à l'esprit lorsqu'il
s'agit des territoires et donc les
maires sont finalement entre les deux un
acteur reconnu à qui on doit faire
confiance et un président qui
effectivement par là une opinion qui ne
s'est pas forcément de quoi il s'agit
quand on parle aussi des territoires la
taxe d'habitation la taxe d'habitation
ça passe toujours pas julia mouzon bon
ça commence à dater c'était au début du
du quinquennat franchement on n'est pas
surpris que le prix noailles public
revienne pas dessus à quelques mois
d'une élection présidentielle vous vous
y attendiez pas non plus franchement oui
absolument d'ailleurs ni l'art il a
souligné dans son discours l'absence de
grandes réformes territoriales suite aux
lois notre et madame du quinquennat
précédent effectivement non sur ce sujet
là je pense qu'il ya vraiment des
espaces politiques locaux et emmanuel
macron aurait pu reconnaître ces espaces
politiques david lisnard a beaucoup
insisté sur les responsabilités et les
prérogatives des maires notamment le
sujet de l'urbanisme le président m'a
république lui est resté effectivement
dans cette dans cette posture plus
professoral et au final on se rend
compte que la vision jupitérienne qu'il
a du pouvoir est incompatible avec cette
notion de décentralisation et les
attentes des élus qui sont une attente
de co construction et de coopération
dans les territoires
oui il me semblait il me semble qu'il ya
un grand grand absent là depuis le début
de ce congrès des maires c'est jean
castex je vous rappelle que quand même
emmanuel macron est allé le chercher
pour que ce soit le drh des mers pas
jean castex c'est quand même le chef des
territoires il représente ça c'est lui
qui doit faire le lien entre les maires
et le président en question est ce que
le président doit être obligatoirement
en lien direct avec les maires je ne
sais pas est ce que ce sont ces c'est
parmi ses prérogatives
est ce que est ce que ccco si c'est
bénéfique pour la cité dans son désir il
a rappelé que jean castex était maire de
village de ville de 6000 l'amc emmanuel
macron ils sont quand même à premier
ministre oui entre mais c'est
intéressant parce que moi je pense que
c'est un atout jean castex encore
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs il sillonne la
france depuis depuis des mois catherine
tricot c'est un atout territoire quand
même effectivement c'est peut-être pour
ça qu'il a été choisi le seul territoire
oui c'est monsieur territoire mais c'est
une problème je pensais qu'il ne porte
pas une vision de la dynamique des
territoires ces dérives
il parle de déterrer de la proximité ils
partent supporter discours de la
proximité mais ce que les maires et
notamment ce qu'a dit david lisnard
c'est à dire la question de l'urbanisme
qui est beaucoup plus structurantes ça
c'est pas à l'échelle d'une ville de
6000 habitants que ça se joue ces
liaisons je d'urbanisme qui sont au
coeur des prérogatives des municipalités
qui sont centrales dans la définition de
notre pays et dans la manière qu'elles
nous allons vivre pour le réchauffement
climatique pour le logement pour les
transports connaissez bien vous êtes
architecte c'est ça
mais ce que je dis c'est que c'est ce
sont des enjeux qui sont tout à fait
structurée qui sont en dehors du
logiciel d'emmanuel macro complètement
lui c'est la technique
l'inventivité etc c'est ça sont son
registre ça peut servir aussi en matière
d'urbanisme dont je ne dis pas ça ne
puisse pas servir mais est-ce que dire
c'est que c'est passé il pense que le
coeur du réacteur c'est l'invention
technique et la science est pas du tout
la dynamique territoriale au travers de
l'urbanisme ou au travers de la
mobilisation des populations et cas sexe
ne portent pas ça veut dire jean castex
ne portent ils portent le côté sympa du
territoire de proximité mais c'est plus
que ça ce qu'on attend aujourd'hui on
attend il peut y avoir simplement les
start up et le territoire de proximité
on veut une vision dans lequel le
territoire et des habitants jouent leur
place et là je crois que là c'est
totalement défaillant dans le discours
et le le personnel que porte fa qui
entourent emmanuel macron n'y en a pas
deux finalement il n'y a pas de grands
élus maintenant que collomb a disparu du
paysage après sa défaite cinglante à
lyon parce que lui il avait quelque
chose à dire sur le sujet on pouvait
partager ou ne pas partager mais que
l'on avait vraiment un une idée de ce
que c'est que une métropole un
territoire dynamique comme on le met en
mouvement et c'est donc que l'on a été
battue et depuis bas depuis alors je
voulais revenir vous y avez fait
référence tout à l'heure laurence
lemouzy à cette partie du discours c'est
assez court mais c'est vrai qu'un des
reproches qu'on fait mal quand on l'a
fait nous même quand on était au congrès
des maires mardi avec nos invités s'est
fait qu'il n'ait pas été lui-même élu au
mr on écoute comment il a réagi à ça
il se peut qu'il y ait eu des
malentendus au début
il se peut d'ailleurs qu'il y ait eu des
préjugés
et
j'assume ne pas avoir été mort
vous avez pour toutes celles et ceux qui
m'ont croisé à travers le grand débat et
beaucoup d'autres j'espère pu découvrir
que j'aime et malgré tout beaucoup de
ski et votre action et je pense qu'il ya
d'ailleurs peu de mes prédécesseurs qui
ont passé autant de temps à débattre
avec les maires partout à travers la
france
c'est ainsi je ne suis d'ailleurs pas le
seul président de la vème république à
ne pas avoir été maire j'ai compris
qu'on en aurait beaucoup le général de
gaulle ces derniers temps se peut qu'il
ait lui-même défaut laurence lusis quand
même assez à lille de vous comparer au
général de gaulle via une de ses
faiblesses supposées quoi c'est c'est
très très habile c'est très habile
alors pour il yad'autres habilité aussi
c'est qu'il ne se déclare jamais ni
girondins ni jacobins
qu'il est il est un peu à la fois les
deux mais est ce que c'est vraiment une
faiblesse pour vous le fait de ne pas
avoir une mère non je ne pense pas parce
qu'il a mes yeux il se rattrape
largement lorsqu'il dit une vérité en
tout cas du point de vue de l'histoire
et de la démarche scientifique
lorsqu'il dit arrêter d'opposer l'état
et les collectivités
la puissance publique c'est l'état et
les collectivités et l'état c'est vous
ça c'est une liste c'est un débat motif
c'est un débat mortifère et il a raison
parce qu'il infecte les relations entre
les deux alors qu'aujourd'hui le
chaînage entre les collectivités et
entre les collectivités locales et
majeur est important et lorsqu'il parle
de ce doux mots un peu barbare de
subsidiarité
je pense que il veut nous faire rentrer
dans une époque de gouvernance
territoriale ou la subsidiarité du poète
c'est à dire si vous êtes capable à
votre niveau de faire quelque chose on
vous aidera on viendra l'état ne viendra
qu'en suppléance
c'est aussi faire confiance à la société
civile et les élus locaux ne sent pas
non plus porteur d'un intérêt général
exclusif de toutes les forces qui
vibrionne sur les territoires julia
mouzon sur ce sur ce thème là
effectivement ne peut pas
systématiquement opposé les les
territoires les élus locaux et l'état et
en l'occurrence l'exécutif les uns et
les autres servent la république oui
évidemment maintenant ce qu'on constate
quand même deux puisque les maires
constate depuis le début du quinquennat
c'est que les territoires ne sont pas
dans les priorités des manuels maquereau
et le regardent les manuels matheron est
davantage tournée vers l'économie
internationale et les enjeux de l'union
européenne que vers les petits villages
est un très bon exemple de ça c'est jean
castex qui a été interpellé sur
l'abaissement du seuil d'obligation de
parité sur les listes électorales donc
en dessous des vis de moi enfin pour les
villes de moins de 1000 habitants et qui
avait l'air de découvrir le sujet qui
avait l'air de découvrir le rapport déjà
rendu par deux députés qui on peut dire
s'est pris les pieds dans le tapis par
ailleurs jean castex qui a en charge la
politique du gouvernement mais bon comme
autour de cette table est plutôt des
gens critiquent j'essaye de ressortir
certains arguments quand même et
notamment les arguments que le président
a rappelé dans son discours il ya le
programme coeur de ville alors là vous
êtes vous êtes directement concernés
julia mouzon le projet coeur de ville
c'est effectivement des initiatives
alors c'est très locales qui sont aidées
par l'état on est dans le concret et
c'est là pour le coup une aile de l'état
vous devez
être satisfaite de ce programme coeur de
ville non je pense que je pense vraiment
et sincèrement qu'il y a une vraie
volonté du président de la république de
travailler avec les territoires et de
faire confiance aux élus locaux
maintenons la dimension complète et
totale de cette confiance elle n'est pas
atteinte parce que je pense que ça n'est
pas dans le logiciel du président de la
république encore une fois david lisnard
lapointe est aussi là il a critiqué les
appels à projets lancé par le
gouvernement qui l'a identifié comme
étant une espèce de tentatives justement
de recentralisation des politiques et de
mainmise du pouvoir central sur les
politiques locales donc la définition de
ces espaces politiques qui est très
complexe au niveau local comme ça a été
soulignée entre des communes les
intercommunalités les départements des
régions donc très complexe et parfois
aussi très difficile à cerner entre les
pouvoirs du maire et du gouvernement ça
a été le cas par exemple sur le court n
1 les russes emmanuel macron a du mal à
cerner ce point là et a laissé aux élus
locaux leur vrai leur véritable place
politique
est-ce qu'il est sûre sur ce thème de la
proximité des terrils voir comment tu
justement dans l'opinion le présent la
république et est perçu c'est peut-être
parce qu'il se rend premier qualificatif
quand on parle de manuel mann non c'est
pas un trait d'image sur déterminant aux
trésors de la république ça c'est vrai
la française emilie oui voilà non mais
ce qu'est ce qui est vrai c'est que tout
au long du du quinquina il a il a quand
même imprimer cette image de président
13h13 verticale et je pense que ça a été
plutôt plutôt assumer ce qui
m'interpelle c'est qu'effectivement on a
une évolution quand même du discours
entre une façon de s'adresser peut être
un petit peu d'un ton un peu professoral
de contrôle envers les territoires à une
collaboration presque un petit peu forcé
aussi par par les crises ont bien deux
ans viennent de souligner donc à mon
sens je pense que manuel macron il est
aussi dense est dans cette posture de
deux prises
en considération de cette importance
finalement d'être au plus près
aujourd'hui de peut-être du maillon un
peu manquant qu'il a dans son logiciel
convient de dire est qu'il n'est pas
vous avez raison de dire a porté aussi
par son cercle le plus le plus proche et
je pense que ça c'est une vraie c'est un
c'est un manque qu'il essaie de qu'il
essaie de combler et je crois
effectivement que pour le coup il s'y
engage fortement alors la popularité des
manuels macron allait quand même
intéressante à analyser je vais rester
avec vous je vois pas ce que le dernier
ipsos pour le point 17 novembre il ya
quelques jours ainsi on est à 44 cent
d'opinions favorables avec une remontée
assez fort ça fait évidemment pas une
victoire à la présidentielle mais quand
même si on compare des prédécesseurs il
est n'est pas loin de son niveau de
début de quinquennat avec avec cette
popularité oui il est c'est un niveau
qui est très haut ce qui est très fort
c'est qu'il consolide son socle
électoral et d'ailleurs je trouve que
c'est intéressant parce que son socle
électoral il est d'abord urbain
sauf que aujourd'hui on est dans une
dans une période où la démographie la
sociologie des villes va aussi changer
et des territoires va aussi évoluer et
je pense que ça c'est un sujet de long
terme de pérennité presque du mouvement
de la république en marche que de se
dire que encore une fois la question est
ce qu'on peut se passer des territoires
c'est à dire des non pas des grandes
espaces métropolitains mais aussi du
monde rural ça sera peut-être l'un des
enjeux du prochain a évolué et comment
elle c'est à dire qu'effectivement il ya
une démographie qui va changer circuler
les grands centres mais bon peut-être
aussi perdre un petit peu de leur de
leur influence et je pense qu'il ya eu
une vraie aspiration qui est s c'est
tout ce que vous êtes en train de dire
si je comprends bien sûr pas dire qu'il
ya une transhumance
on quitte la ville jamais les gens qui
quittent la ville sans les mêmes qui
était oui mais les exigences dont vient
seulement les exigences on ne change pas
bien sûr et chansons de vote en fonction
de où on habite shah ancien alors dans
sélection des ans artiste alors le cadre
de vie a une influence un énorme aussi
sur le faire chanter en veux absolument
comportement électoral en termes de de
mobilisation d'exigence de nouveaux
critères ça
s'arrête là mais non mais en tout cas
prochainement d'autres éléments abordés
qui a été évoqué c'était évidemment la
la crise qu vides comment les maires ont
été en première ligne alors il ya 2 il
ya deux sous-thèmes dans ce thème est la
question des finances on pouvait
s'attendre ça faisait partie des rumeurs
qui était qui courait dans les couloirs
du congrès des maires à ce que emmanuel
macron lâche une partie des six
milliards qu'ils étaient qui sont
réclamés par parler par les élus julien
mouzon je viens vers vous parce que
alors sur cet aspect là il ya pas eu un
mot pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
compensation de de l'état pourquoi vous
l'a réclamé cette compensation et qu'est
ce que ça vous inspire la réponse de
madame mâcon ou la non réponse alors le
voilà moi je ne suis pas je ne suis pas
élu local semblait effectivement les
deuxièmes locale
oui tout à fait et effectivement
effectivement suite à la crise tout le
monde fait un peu les comptes et il ya
ce constat de l'impact économique de la
crise dans des territoires et donc des
demandes de compensations mais j'ai
envie de dire qu'ils vont au delà parce
que ça fait longtemps que les élus
dénoncent la baisse des dotations la
baisse des financements le sujet de la
taxe d'habitation s'ajoutent à ces
airbags précédent et puis au niveau du
corona virus on a eu le sentiment en
tout cas ça a été dénoncé notamment
dénoncée par les élus locaux de
cafouillage avec ses arbitrages laisser
aux élus locaux mais en dernière minute
évidemment les élus souhaitent davantage
d'autonomie mais c'est compliqué quand
on vous dit pour le jour pour le
lendemain qu'il faut décider de
l'ouverture des parcs ou des écoles etc
donc il ya ces éléments qui sont qui
sont difficiles une crise qui a été
complexe et comme c'est la première fois
effectivement des frontières nouvelles à
tracer dans un contexte global de
réduction du budget des collectivités
laurence lemouzy le deuxième aspect de
ce thème épidémie c'est la cinquième
vague la reprise de l'économie c'est une
eco s de l'épidémie c'est une équation à
plusieurs une présidentielle c'est une
équation à plusieurs inconnues et là
c'est une inconnue supplémentaire faire
qu'on ne sait pas l'impact que ça pourra
avoir sur la campagne et donc sur le
bilan des manuels macron salle e s que
vous diriez que ça le place sur un fil
ça fait longtemps quand même qu'il est
sûre sur le fil de bien des crises et
ils sont nés il s'en est sorti et puis
en double pour l'instant elle lui a
plutôt profité la crise en termes de
popularité parce qu'il a ce pardon vous
intéresse mais ce ce costume de
protecteur dans l'excitation et dans les
ici oui mais on est dans l'état
providence est né dans l'état protecteur
mais si on sait pas ce qui va se passer
là dans les prochains mois
comme en politique tout peut arriver le
jeu peut être vitres battu mais il a
fait ce qu'il y a quand même un discours
un peu hors sol la posture la chanson de
geste au niveau national entre les élus
locaux et et le gouvernement met en
pratique quand même le récit justement
de la discorde de la plainte l'état
travaille avec les collectivités il y a
des il y à il ya des choses qui sont
parce que emmanuel macron a sans doute
compris avec ses crises que le quotidien
était stratégique et que l'état n'était
pas en capacité d'assurer ce quotidien
parce que les compétences avaient été
transférés et qu'il fallait et
d'ailleurs il a compensé à l'euro près
la taxe d'habitation c'est un peu un
mauvais procès là où peut-être les élus
en raison symboliquement il ya un lien
qui est coupée entre le fait de voter de
voter et de payer un impôt sur un
territoire dans lequel on habite donc là
il ya un peu une fracture mais il dit
quand même aux élus inventez votre
propre imaginaire arrêtez de vous
abriter sous l'état sous l'abri de
l'état inventez votre propre récit
allez-y comme il le dit à d'autres
publics au statut peur aux entrepreneurs
il faut il en pullule ceux de l'énergie
eon la critique est là je le soutiens un
peu dans sa démarche il faut quand même
que les les élus se mettent en mouvement
et que peut-être la prochaine étape
l'avenir c'est qu'ils aient des options
claires pourquoi ne pas avoir un pouvoir
normatif territoriale la norme des fois
absurde en tram la gestion du quotidien
et si elle a d adapter si les lois
étaient moins de valeur de bavarder et
s'il y avait un parlementarisme régional
qui réveillé le débat public parce qu'il
ya une crise politique ce sera un an ce
sera mes anciens pour être le premier et
dernier thème dont on n'a pas parlé
jouer qu'on les voit qu'avec vous
laetitia c'est là
la posture et la
personnalité david lisnard qui voilà qui
est prend donc la présidence de
l'association des maires de france et là
l'information de la journée d'hier est
due à plus de 60% des des voix alors il
ya deux aspects il va peut-être
s'imposer un nouveau personnel dans le
paysage de la droite mais ce qu'il peut
être un caillou dans la chaussure des
macros mais disons qu'il ne lui
simplifie pas la tâche du tout parce que
au-delà d'être évidemment une figure des
républicains il est aussi dans tout cas
l'enjeu de d'emmanuel mâcon de se
réinventer parce que c'est vraiment l'un
c'est dans cinq mois donc il a intérêt à
nous sortir un autre récit lui qui aime
écrire ce roman national il faut
absolument à mon sens à un autre version
est donc david lisnard il est un peu sur
le chemin des manuels macron pourquoi
parce que c'est un peu son double c'est
à dire qu'il est charismatique même si
ça c'est pas vraiment vu l'abondance ont
en tout cas il est adoubé par la presse
thomas il crève l'écran j'ai lu ça dans
le parisien et alors le point qui
commence le journal le point qui
commence son portrait en dix ans c'est
un homme de racines et de conviction
flamboyant et créatif donc ça vous
rappelle peut-être quelqu'un en 2016 la
presse était tout vraiment c'était
unanime un bienveillante à l'égard d'
emmanuel macron et en plus ce mr là vous
le disiez à l'instant il s'est fait
remarquer pendant la crise sanitaire il
a proposé des choses plus ou moins
farfelues ou sonner quand il a fait
arroser la avec des drones asperger de
bactéries s'ils savent ils enfin en tout
cas il a tenté des choses il est allé
chercher les masques et on l'a vraiment
connu en tout cas le grand public a fait
sa connaissance à cette occasion là et
les des porte parole de françois fillon
mais ça on l'a un peu
il me semble et en plus c'est l'ami des
stars grâce au festival
moto festival de cannes avec spielberg
et nicole kidman à qui il a appris à
tweeté voyez enfin brian bordo
cette voie là il ya un peu de macron
dans david lisnard qui a ce côté double
mais il ya aussi un côté anti tél ben
oui parce que il a fait les cette
tribune assassine la en novembre 2020
sur la bureaucratie qui étouffe l'action
de l'état qui paralyse l'état et c'est
ce fil qu'ils tirent depuis notamment
hier quand il a pris la parole juste
après son élection c'était sur le
plateau de public sénat c'est pas que
j'attende d'emmanuel maintenant
j'attends du chef de l'état en france
qu'il dirige bien l'état qu'il assume
les fonctions régaliennes de l'état et
qui laisse les mairies faire leur job en
assurant une péréquation juste et
l'égalité territoriale
c'est aussi simple que cela le que soit
le chef de l'état ouais voilà fond
quelles que soient ses quand même
message et mais emmanuel macron en tout
cas c'est vrai que ce message de
bureaucratie trop lourde et qui paralyse
encore une fois l'action de l'état ça a
été vérifié avec les masses cette
histoire de masse fiasco qui lui colle
quand même à la pohdh emmanuel macron
donc ça on imagine que david lisnard va
continuer sur ce chemin là je vous
rappelle quand même qu'il a laissé
planer le doute très longtemps sur sa
potentielle entrée en campagne pour la
présidentielle donc il sait qu'il a un
potentiel et un destin peut-être
nationale donc il va jouer je à mon avis
troubles jusqu'à la fin six morceaux il
n'est pas encore
connus ou très connu du grand public six
mois
lisnard non non elle n'est pas très
connue et en même temps on est quand
même face à une opinion publique qui se
désintéresse tellement de l'envers du
décor politique que même sur des
personnages que nous on commence tous
les jours et un taux de notoriété assez
faible et je pense que pour le coup
cette campagne présidentielle vous avez
raison de le rappeler elles placent au
coeur de tous deux de l'enjeu la notion
j'aime bien cette notion de créativité
pour le coup sur les cinq dernières
années à mon sens ce qu'on était quand
même le plus créatif ces acteurs de
proximité et je pense qu emmanuel macron
aussi saisi l'opportunité d'aller
prendre le pouls de ses territoires
créatif merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat c'était
passionnant